okay that was a uh I well I think we're
going to get back to the journey so back
to what you asked about yeah no no no
we're we're going to dive into this okay
cool I have I I've sat with many many
Founders in the seat um I haven't heard
many start out by saying yes this is not
my first rodeo but this is my life
mission right it is so what is that
about
[Music]
it fredman welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here 20
minutes thank you for hosting me of
course we're going to run for a little
bit more than 20 minutes cuz for the
things that I have here it's uh way too
much um really excited to have you here
Tomar um we started to get to know each
other over the last few months last time
we spent in Seattle right at a us we'll
both reinvent and previously um with the
with the accelerator today you're
running Cotto uh this is not your first
startup it's not your first rodeo um not
the first complex deep Tech Journey that
you're on and you know in preparation
for this conversation getting to look at
the breadth of things that you got to
deal with the breadth of experiences
that you've had from your military
service to your academic career to H the
organizations that you've been a part of
from startups to uh larger companies
like Alibaba and and uh working on a
variety of different tasks from Vision
to to now a code generation and and even
much more than code generation so really
really interesting and I'd love to start
there I'd love to hear a little bit
about how you got even into this startup
and high-tech scene yeah sure so first
it isn't my first rodeo not my first
starter for example but it is my life
mission except of course family you know
things like that um this is really
really my life mission and we're
probably going to talk about it I think
what we're doing at codo uh to put it
the most simple way like code testing
code review actually we frame it as code
integrity and if you you know take it a
broader aspect of it it's like verifying
the Integrity of the code that is being
generated by AI it's going to be so
important for the future of humanity I'm
not kidding so although like it is like
another step in my career I see as like
as the most important and critical one
probably going to invest my life into it
okay that was a uh I well I think we're
going to get back to the journey so back
to what you asked about yeah no no no
we're going to dive into this okay cool
I have I I've sat with many many
Founders in the seat um I haven't heard
many start out by saying yes this is not
my first rodeo but this is my life
mission right it is so what is that
about yeah
um I I think like at this point people
don't think I'm crazy anymore like uh
for example my wife before the chat
before like BC before chat GPT she was
like Hey like you're putting you know
your your thoughts and life into AI in a
way that is slightly
disturbing and uh it was quite hard to
uh explain how I think about uh the
impact of AI is going to have on each
one of us on our lives and I think at
this point there is consensus it's
mainstream that going to change like we
don't it's hard for us to predict
exactly how uh but I think like many
people understand it's going to change
even my wife now is continuously like
she's a physician continuously using
chat GPT and before that she thought
it's never going to work or be
ridiculous and and and so as we like
going to discuss like how the future of
AI uh is going to evolve I think that we
can agree that AI is going to know to
write code really really well and it's
going to be a fundamental tool for the
AI uh wherever it's going to work
whether in robotics or whether in
software development or biology or
security it's going to write code as as
it progress like it's going to be like
that's assumption that I have in my my
mind and if it writes code with no human
review at all and it's just going to run
it and use it it's going to be really
critical that it's going to be done in a
way way that is safe that it's aligned
with our values and align with the uh
Creator value the the user value the
civilization values Etc and it's a bit
far right now like directly to what what
we're doing at Cotto but it's actually
uh very connected like in the most
fundamental like most like a simple way
like what we're doing is code testing
and code review but when you look on
Koto tool and sorry for the Shameless
plug here when you look on Cotto's tool
one of the thing that we're we're trying
to do uh with Cotto merge for example
it's the pull request agent uh we're
trying to verify best practice of the
organization now right now the best
practice of the organization is like you
know engineering best practice because
right now ai is writing like components
but when it writes like uh like Full
Features end to endend the best practice
is not only like make it maintainable
this way or use SQL SQL like this way
it's like hey we want to make sure that
you're not writing this stuff into the
database or you're not sending that data
or you're not going to ruin that it's
going to be much more high level even in
the even in the matter of values of of
the company and and that's for me is
going to I think it's going to be really
critical for for us companies and and
the civilization I'm I'm serious about
that so help me make this distinction I
remember 5 years back there was a really
interesting start by a good friend of
mine Shimon told
and he was looking at how to take if I
remember correctly pull requests on
GitHub and in Enterprises and being able
to identify misconfigurations in policy
Secrets different things that that
Engineers did human Le errors that are
not in line with the security posture
policies of the organization Y and it
sounds to me like you're looking almost
at this sort of this in similar in the
similar area where there's the activity
of we're generating these features or
these Solutions and we want to integrate
them into the larger ecosystem of our
organization or to deploy them to
customers and there's a set of things
that we need to check for as we do that
but it sounds like you're talking about
a massive shift and evolution right that
we need to check for so can you dive in
a bit more about that yeah of course so
Shimon and what they did in the tree for
example is very specific it's very
technical yeah uh and there's many other
like there is sonar Cube whatever like
linting for example of code but as a AI
progress uh in in both side of the
equation the code generation but also
verifying its intent its correctness its
alignment uh with your best practices
Etc it could go higher level than like
technically make sure it didn't
configure something badly rather that
for example uh you're not uh sharing uh
information between two users uh in
order to uh convert one of the users to
pay uh to pay more or buy something uh
like this is not according to the value
of the company but no one is going to
look at that code right at some point so
you need to make sure that there's
another uh piece of software which is
also AI that will make sure that this
best practice actually happens that that
uh uh our AI is developing a feature and
and there is some product manager that
told it I want 2% more convergence on
this uh with this type of feature uh
generate me a few options it got an it
got an option but it doesn't know what's
doing under the under the hood because
right now like there's no developer uh
in most Cas is reviewing it I'm talking
about the future not right now right
like 5 years from now so at that point
we need to have all those that AI those
systems that not only checks like the
configuration is right and there is no
functional problem or performance
problem but actually also align with the
values of what what you how you wanted
the software to behave so what I'm
saying is that at Cotto we're building
towards that future like we already have
a few features of that but obviously
it's not there yet because also the
other side is not there yet the code
generation is not there yet you're
seeing like amazing stuff on on Twitter
X and whatever LinkedIn a 7 years old uh
girl building softare but or or a
freelancer like a a pumer like a
professional doing a website in 3 hours
or 3 minutes instead of three weeks but
that's not complicated software AI is
not there yet like we're now in in uh
and beginning of 2025 right when while
we're recording is not yet like uh
change completely changeed the Paradigm
in complex software development but it's
going to happen and and I actually think
it's going to happen in like late 25 26
and when that happen we need to also be
ready to protect oursel security uh uh
like testing but also on especially as
we progress 2027 28 on the integrity and
that's why I'm saying like uh it's my
life mission because I think it's it's
important for Humanity think like there
could be so many crowd strike moments
sorry crowd strike like just it's a
really good example yeah and but also
that's like a very technical thing but
there also could be like weird stuff
that Crow strike like and we want to
prevent that so I I think it's it's
really critical and and that's why I'm
saying that yeah I'm I want I want to
get back to the Integrity in a minute
because I think that there's interesting
um even half philosophical questions
about you know what what you know what
is the world that we're entering and
what would it what could it look like
with high integrity with with with
integrity that's L there's you're
alluding to the crowd strike moments
right where there's massive disruptions
because of some because
of software that's not that's either not
secure or not operating correctly but
but I think there's also could be
misalignment in the values which you
bring into the software itself that's my
point right and then we're looking at
Healthcare we're looking at military
we're looking at energy nuclear right so
many different everything in everything
in the world but I want to hear a little
bit about your perspective so you've
been following you see you started Kota
almost 3 years ago two and a half years
ago right in July of 201 yeah we we like
the paper like sorry for interrupting
the the the like the pen dropped on
we're going to start doing this and and
uh that was that was July and actually
like starting like like
moving fastly with recruiting people Etc
was around September where we raised our
SE series uh our seed so I would say
like around September 2022 like so about
three months before chpt yeah like yeah
that's how I like to say two three
months BC before chpt no it's funny I
I'm I'm curious to hear what what what
triggered it I was in in July of 2022 I
was with Innovation Endeavors and I
remember I was um I spent about a year
diving into llms and into the emergence
of of deep learning in the context also
of security and I was presenting this
100 100 slide presentation to the team
about okay here's where llms were from
bag of words all the way to now I don't
know what's going to happen next but
it's coming yeah and the and the cat is
out of the box but what prompted you to
start sure what was what was that
defining moment yeah sure and this way I
can also like finally like relate to my
past that you wanted to me to relate to
so really quickly um I'll I'll do like
samples from my history because it's
it's related so for example as a student
I worked in melanox uh later to be
acquired by Nvidia it's an really
awesome company and what I did there is
actually verification uh I did also some
you know module like uh like chip design
Etc but I actually weirdly likeed the
verification part which is
usually and U yeah and and um and and
and like what I like what I like doing
there is automating the verification um
that's like and then the interesting
thing is that when you do that for
Hardware it's like actually makes a lot
of sense that you can actually do that
even in 20 20 10 or 2006 even why that's
where where I did that because when
you're thinking about hard it's bites in
bites out um and then you can do like
stuff like formal verification and other
type of verification that you can
automate with regular uh algorithms Etc
um and then I I I asked myself like
because I I was doing software
development at the same time can I apply
these like techniques also to software
and my answer was quickly no because in
software like 90% of the case I I don't
have like exact number but it's not
bites in bites out it's story in story
out out like how do you do the software
development you have user stories you
have Dev stories there are stories like
the natural language human stories you
have to have machine learning to to
close that Gap uh I I did like my
bachelor master degree in the techum and
I did a few stuff and my last a few
things my last company was acquired by
Alibaba let's skip how that happened
like we basically uh uh aimed for the
Chinese and uh uh and APAC uh as the
target market ala was our biggest
customer Etc and actually weirdly
probably I had like really good time in
in Alibaba I think like there's less
than 10 entrepreneur tell you that are
doing good time in in in Enterprise let
alone a Chinese one but one of the
reason is because Alibaba is an amazing
school for machine learning so I did
machine learning from 2006 but but uh
you know like what you said like XG
boost and whatever and 2010 I I did like
a neural NE or five lay four layers
sorry and but but there was an amazing
school and um and and during what I call
the golden golden time of the research
era like uh like 2017 to 2021 is when
the research flourished and now we're
talking about commercial of right so
that was amazing like um and during this
time like every time someone told me AI
I was like a bit like puking inside and
and okay I can play ball but I would
call it ML and I I didn't want to call
AI but by the end of
2021 as a team that was building
Foundation models and auto M like we
were starting oursel to realize that hey
we're starting to do stuff that does
feel like intelligent to some extent and
uh uh and and then like I started also
writing posts on on medium like early
2022 interesting people like wrote me
like you're
hallucinating about the effect effect of
that uh right now it's like a really
funny like you brought the term for us
yeah and and and and then like like I
realized that that copilot and uh and
Etc just the beginning because in
complex software like bringing back my
history in complex software and complex
uh Hardware Etc like writing the uh
writing the the ver log vhdl or software
like just like maybe uh 10% 15% 30% of
what you do the most all the rest like
is a lot about verifying that what
you're actually doing works because the
cost of shipping Hardware that doesn't
work or the cost of breaking an app that
is in charge of Transportation fin
Services is so high that you need to put
effort into that and then I thought it's
it's time like uh that that like we try
to tackle that really hard problem which
is not solved even until today right
like I'm not saying D Coto solved
testing or code
review 100% if we did that I would a win
the novel price and be like uh uh you no
solve softer right if you solve testing
inw absolutely so if if we're actually
looking from I guess late
2021 um
or even if we we can go even a little
bit back so you know I remember you know
even when I was still in my Army service
you know writing code you know we had
all we had these amazing tools you know
intellisense and a bunch of these tools
that helped us be more productive in the
IDE and obviously we had stack Overflow
and thing it feels like the velocity is
constantly changing in the context of
code code generation a lot of people are
talking about how AI is evolving at an
incredible Pace you know I'm looking at
it in the context of of diffusion models
and and guns right in the context of
video and audio and I'm really curious
to hear you to hear though your P your
perspective on the velocity of change of
yeah AI in the context of text and in as
it pertains to code generation because
you really get a FR row seat to it from
the very beginning awesome so first I
want to say that um I think um um
Evolution progress is actually uh a
concatination of s shaped
progress um and the thing is that um and
and Ray courtz uh and Singularity is
near and now there's the book
singularities near that I didn't read
yet but I have to uh talks about like
something similar that that the speed of
um like technology progress is is is is
growing like likeor the second order uh
positive second order and and and and
what I think is actually the SC curves
are getting closer to each other like
you have those escar and and the thing
is that the breakthroughs uh that
enables those escar are getting closer
and closer and one one thing I I want to
say that I think one of the most
important like uh uh breakthroughs we
must have is actually uh energy because
if you really want to deploy um AI in in
scale like right now uh the the the
bottleneck I think is like the hardware
and um and energy mostly and not about
algorithms or or data and that's why you
see like companies like Google uh Oracle
AWS buying like nuclear power and
station sorry Etc and and and I think we
will need to see more more progress
there or things like like I just I just
mentioned because I think think in in
fact um that at this moment I'm not sure
that models llms are the bottleneck
anymore I'm not I'm not saying we can't
progress further uh for example uh
inference time or test time like uh uh
scale if you know what I'm talking about
I'm saying like until today like when
you ask a model to uh solve a task
predict make a prediction or or so it
will just run one time the run the model
once and now there's architectures like
you see in the models 01 03 by open AI
that can actually go back and run a few
times for one query and decide about
that themselves um so that's like kind
of a breakr that we knew it's going to
happen it's not like the concept is
wasn't new but but now the Kno hows are
there to make it happen so I'm not that
that's very important like for for the
model being able to think a bit further
like uh we can talk about it later
system one system two like um and and uh
but at the same time I don't think right
now uh that's uh what's stopping us I I
think um it's a matter of uh of energy
um and uh matter of uh a few actually
engineering breakthrough we we can we
can talk about and and therefore um I
think that we we are still going to see
a lot of progress in in in applications
in the use of AI because we don't get in
my opinion uh um uh like fully
exploiting uh the llm at this moment uh
let me clarify just to make sure I'm
thinking I'm saying that the
Breakthrough happened of the large
language models being able to do uh uh
self uh uh um unsupervised learning
being able to use reinforcement learning
to get to these awesome models and we
are going to progress but now I'm
claiming that we're in the middle of the
scurve uh and and mostly like now
actually applying application we see
encoding support security and there's a
lot more to to uh um value to attract
from there and then I think the next
breakthroughs are actually in my opinion
is going to be like uh on Frontier that
is going to help us um like use that and
scale and that's why in my opinion you
see like companies like uh we just today
morning there was a a new Stargate or
whatever I forgot the name announcement
500 billion yeah on on building AI
infrastructure invest yeah it's an
infrastructure notice that they're
focusing on infrastructure on the
hardware on the energy and and that
that's I think uh where we we're aiming
at and and and that's why I think like
also like the progress is going to
happen fast because we didn't yet got to
the top of the scurve of like exploiting
the application Etc and when we get
there I think like a lot of uh resources
being built to also uh uh um cross the
next S curve which is which is in my
opinion going to be energy Hardware Etc
I think it's such an interesting um
point of view and one that I that I
fully agree with and I think just
considering this question of what are
the Breakthrough what are the
breakthroughs that we need to
distinguish and then what are just
efforts that need to be done to then you
know exploit use these break breaks and
hearing you know your perspective that
you know yes there are going to be
obviously more research breakthroughs in
AI over the years right I'm and I'm
excited about the way that AI is going
to have to also be able to look at the
physical world and make sense of it um
in in different ways like what F Le is
trying to do but yeah you know but
thinking about the way that you're
looking at okay so there we had these
significant breakthroughs in llms we are
now just scratching the tip of the
iceberg on what's possible to do right
and we're at the precipice of the
creation of this new found
infrastructure the energy that's going
to help bring now the application layer
and the commercialization layer here and
and I think that that's just um it's
just very exciting yeah so I can relate
to the coding specifically that I didn't
mention because I I didn't want to like
lay the ground about like uh the AI
breakthroughs and progress in general so
I think like coding is a good example
that on one hand we already using llms
quite nicely to ress faster with
software development and in in some
aspect of software development I do
think there is a paradigm shift I call
that like the simple software uh right
now like I mentioned before you can do
simple like a like a blog or or simple
website that take you three weeks to
develop or you would use Wicks to to
build now you can build like I don't
just like a number three hours and get
the code and and um and as a different
than Wix for example and that's like a
paradigm shift uh but I think um uh we
are not there yet as I mentioned right
now early 2025 with parttime shift in in
complex software but I don't think it's
an llm Balck anymore now there's a need
to uh use the llms like like I mentioned
again Shameless plug for properly set
the ground to use use thei set set the
the systems in engineering to use AI for
testing code review uh understanding uh
complex and and wide con uh uh code
bases uh reading uh your your
documentation and and uh different
technical um do documents and and design
uh documents uh reading your uh uh test
plans reading like there's a lot of
reading and digestion that needs to be
done in order to really put AI on each
part in each like sub workflow on the
overall software development life cycle
of complex software and I don't say
think the llm is the bottom L anymore
it's now a lot of engineering work that
is Expediting as well because a lot of
those companies that are doing that are
dog footing on on themselves and and
that's why like although it seems a bit
far I think we will see in complex
software a paradigm shift like it's hard
to imagine right now but by the end of
2025 early uh 2026 so I think like I
didn't relate to that I think like the
untapped like areas is around code
review code testing and and just because
I I I'm like we're leading Coto I want
to give another evidence is like the CEO
of AWS uh he stood on uh in a keynote
and reinvent like just a couple of
months ago and he said hey we checked
with fortun 5,000 companies and an
average a developer write code one hour
a day and all the rest is actually and
complex software is around testing code
review Etc so like I think it's it's by
by now like quite clear that that this
is where we can use LM to to change
software development and I'm talking
about the next two three years like in
five 10 years is going to be crazier I
think that's I I mean I you know I
started this uh show back in 2020
um it's it's incredible to me constantly
you know the shift in in the tone and
the conversation we were I used to be
talking in 10year lengths predictions
here we're talking about a year and a
half two years and and I think that's
awesome I think that's just incredible
if you had to Think Through over the
last year or so significant
breakthroughs you've experienced not
necessarily just in the technology but
also in the usage and in the way that we
in the way that we use code generation
tools codo different what what
breakthroughs are we actively
experiencing right now or what
breakthroughs are you contributing to
right now yeah awesome so I think we
started like llms are trained to predict
the next token right so it's very
fitting in the uix in user experience
user interface that it will help you to
autocomplete code like predict the next
like uh tab like tap tab tap that like
the next uh uh word or even sentence or
even like a few a few paragraphs ahead
uh so that's what we like that was the
first use cases that really fits the LM
technology and that's like why why I
think there was a great match in product
Market fit Etc um now the thing is that
the breakthroughs that were noticing
thing is that we're able to use models
also to complete tasks end to end not
just autocomplete the next word um for
example um at Coto we released early
2024 is a year ago actually it feels
like a decade at least ago but exactly a
year ago we released Alpha codium um
Alpha codium is our take on Google's
Deep Mind Alpha code uh we have a very
uh uh we have one area in our in our uh
system design that is very different
than than theirs and that's why ours uh
was significantly better in in Alpha
code by Deep Mind what they said is the
model is the most important part that
needs to make the decisions and uh like
and like and all you need to do is just
prompt it many many times so what they
did is trained a model to uh um win
coding competitions okay the context
here is that Alpha code is a is a alpha
code by Deep Mind is a solution that
with a click of a button you can compete
on coding competition uh like similar to
chess.com so there's a competition.com
that's called code forces and what they
did is they trained a model to be really
well work really well in competition and
then given a problem they would call the
model give us 10,000 possible solutions
and then there's another model that for
example chooses the best one and they
submit it that's a workflow we call it a
workflow of two two steps like just the
first step is like you're exhausting the
model there what we did what we did is
build a full workflow and uh like you
can call it if you like an agent
although I think there's a very
important difference between a workflow
agent we can talk about it and Tropic
actually wrote a really good blog about
it and we build a workflow with with 12
steps 12 nodes in the graph and not like
two and part of these nodes were focused
on code in on COD review and we double
the performance and and then then Deep
Mind and we wanted to give them credit
uh that's why we call it Alpha codium um
original name by the way of the company
and the product were was codium c o d IU
M and we changed to codo uh which stands
for quality of development uh and not
just like codium that feels like a code
model or or autocomplete or so so with
Alpha codium like we actually managed to
build a flow uh that with a click of a
buttom you get to a Master Level
programmer in coding competition and if
you plug o1 01 by itself reaches really
good really good like uh accuracy but if
you plug it inside Alpha codium it it
raises the performance of 01 by 50%
that's a lot usually like the uplift
there is is harder uh task harder
question even if you you put the you
compare like uh even to 01 II which was
designed and and like uh uh uh trained
to compete this Alpha does better
with a inferior model we didn't manage
to put our hands on 03 yet and and I
guess that it's happened to say although
03 is reaching by itself a really high
uh score with Alpha coding we think so
back to your point it was like an
example to to to share that workflows
and agents are real breakthroughs and in
2024 we saw them completing simple tasks
end to endend and I think uh and by the
way to be frank simple task and simple
software and I think that in 2025 we're
going to see them solve simple tasks in
complicated software that's a real
paradigm shift in complicated software
and then in 2026 we're going to see them
solve complicated task in complicated
software and then like that's that's the
nailing it the paradigm shift and that
that's the breakthroughs like having
workflow of an agent and not just the
autocomplete uh thingy and you know
you're saying these sentences and uh I'm
I'm translating them in real time in my
head so you know solving simple task
simple software complex task complex
software simple task simple task complex
software so complex software for example
let's look at a nuclear facility simple
task in a nuclear facility let's have it
change from a color red to a color
orange when when it does something right
here here's something very specific I
want you to do complex task and a
complex software like a nuclear facility
let's actually have it rotate at a
different RPM given different conditions
and you should think about what those
conditions are and we're not talking
about 10 years from now uh at least in
and when we're doing that uh make sure
that you're inventing the right tests
the right checks the verifying the the
best practices verifying the values
asking knowing when you need to ask a
human if you're not sure that's part of
the the endtoend task right get get
information that what you would do as a
developer is if your definition that you
got was not clear enough you would go
and ask someone that you feel is in
charge and knows the answers that's also
for me part of those tools that that
models will know how to do when I'm when
I'm saying like not model sorry like
system with no to do when I'm talking
about uh complex uh task and complex
sofware this was such a pleasure thank
you so much for for joining me here this
fun conversation